democrats blame trump for wildfires in
democrat-run areas
cops are blamed yet again for refusing
to be assaulted by blm protesters and
the media go wild over an indoor trump
rally i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online activity should
not be public protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
so this morning i was driving around my
neighborhood in los angeles
and i was observing all the sights and
sounds of los angeles you know like the
smoke in the sky that obscures the sun
so that it feels like you're an
apocalyptic mad max movie
you know the sights of of homeless
people going through your garbage can
like directly in front of your home
and then a few blocks later homeless
people pissing onto the sidewalks
and the sights and sounds of la the
things that make la really really
tremendous but there's one thing
that juxtaposed with all these things
reminds you why la is such a great city
and that is the law in science
see there is this thing that's happened
in la probably over the last few years
where people feel the necessity to put
out a
signal of their own virtue and
wonderfulness
it is a symbol of their own dissociation
from their evil terrible benighted
fellow americans
it's basically like passover for the
social justice
warriors where if you put out this lawn
sign on your lawn then everybody
is supposed to pass right over you
because you are one of the virtuous it's
like blood on the lintel during passover
you're supposed to the gods of social
justice wokeness will pass right over
your home
and move right on to the next home
because you have been touched by the
hand of tolerance
there's this lawn sign again i don't
know if it's an in other cities in la it
is extremely extremely common i would
say that probably
every suburban block in la has three or
four of these
onlines everywhere and these are not
kind of normal political signs that just
say which political candidate you
support
they are semantically overloaded virtue
signaling signs and what they are
truly designed to do is of course
suggest that you are better than other
people you're better than other people
because they are filled
with tautologies that don't mean
anything unless you're in on the coding
unless you're in on the semantic coding
now to remind everybody semantic
overload
is a term that means that sometimes a
tautology or a term
doesn't necessarily mean what it says it
means it can carry a bunch of different
meanings a perfect example of this is of
course the phrase black lives matter
which can mean three separate things it
can mean one
the inarguable proposition that black
people matter and should matter
two the proposition that america is
systemically racist and that a huge
swath of americans don't believe black
lives matter
and three the black lives matter
organization and neo marxist horrible
organization seeking to overturn all
institutions in the united states
so that's what this sign is filled with
and it is put on lawns
by white rich suburban people generally
who have decided it's really important
to signal to their neighbors
what their feelings are we know that
these people are virtuous because
they've put this sign
on their lawn and this all ties into
what we are seeing
in our in our political cycle today
right the the
firm insistence by the media and by
democrats that only democrats believe in
science but this is all part of a
broader rubric which is
we are more virtuous than you we offer
no solutions we offer no policy
prescriptions
in fact there's no reason for us to do
so because we cannot have conversations
with people who do not believe
the following semantically overloaded
tautological statements
we can't even have a conversation with
you because you don't believe what we
believe
you're not even operating in the same
universe that we are operating see
here's the thing when you discuss
solutions
when you discuss policies sometimes you
can find common ground
but if you never discuss solutions and
you never discuss policies and what you
really are attempting to do
is cudgel people with slogans that mean
a lot more than you are saying they mean
when you are playing this mot and bailey
game where you put out the most generic
sounding term
but what you actually mean is something
that is extremely loaded
then what you're really trying to do is
divide people so this lawn sign is not
attempting to unify anybody the law and
sign is deliberately attempting to
divide people
and to give yourself a pat on the back
because you put up a law ensign sure you
may not have given charity to any of the
causes you supposedly support
sure you may not even have thought
through any of these slogans but you got
the lawn sign and that's all that
matters so here's what this lawn sign
says
that again is extremely common in la you
can buy it on amazon for like 1799
because capitalism always wins
from signsofjustice.com this is where
this sign has come from
we believe then it's all in rainbow
colors of course black lives matter now
again semantically
overloaded right usually it says in this
house we believe black lives matter
and what they mean by that of course is
that as opposed to the guy next door
in that house they don't believe black
lives matter that's why we have a sign
and they don't have a sign right so
they're using the semantically
overloaded term black lives matter to
suggest that they are different from
their evil
predatory neighbors who don't care about
black people in this house we believe
black lives matter no human is illegal
except for the ones they are hiring to
uh to trim their lawn presumably because
this is california
no human is illegal now that of course
is a is a bizarre statement
because no one is arguing that being
human is illegal
when we talk about illegal immigration
which is what this is a reference to
what we mean generally is that somebody
has engaged in the crime of crossing the
border illegally
and the hu the being human is not the
illegal part in fact the only people
who seek to criminalize being human are
people who are pro-abortion who
literally say that because you are
you're not a human we get to criminalize
this
okay let's continue with that that sign
okay
love is love right another semantically
overloaded phrase so of course love is
love right that's literally
a tautology a tautology is just a equals
a right love is love that is a taught a
logical statement but of course what
they actually mean
is that all forms of love are equal now
what's funny is that
generally even people who say love is
love don't believe that all
forms of love are equal obviously i mean
they actually have moral standards as
well thank god
right they don't believe that that
homosexuality is on par with
bestiality which it isn't they don't
believe that homosexuality is on par
with
incest which it isn't right so even
people who say love is love don't
actually believe that all love is equal
to all love
because that would be a ridiculous
statement what they actually mean is
that they are just pro-same-sex marriage
but they've decided
that if you don't believe that same-sex
marriage and heterosexual marriage
are obviously of the same political
impact or import or you don't believe
that they're on the same moral level
then this means that you don't believe
that love is love
right you don't believe in the taught
logical statement because you've drawn a
standard
now obviously they draw standards too
it's just a different standard
we in this house we believe women's
rights are human rights and here what
they actually mean is we believe in
abortion
because no one believes that women
shouldn't go to school nobody believes
that women shouldn't be able to get any
job they want to get
no one believes that a qualified woman
shouldn't be able to do the exact same
job as a qualified man
nobody believes anything different in
the united states so again this is an
attempt to suggest that if you disagree
with people on abortion
it's because you don't believe in
women's rights or you don't believe that
women are human
again it's all this this semantically
overloaded virtue signaling crap
we believe science is real okay science
is real
this is the big one for today's show and
for today's news cycle
because the democrats have decided that
they are going to campaign on the slogan
science is real
anybody who opposes them anybody who
believes that they are
reading into the science solutions that
are not requisite
anybody who believes that they're
overreading the science in order to
achieve political
goals which is what is exactly happening
with regard to the wildfire fires and
hurricanes as we'll see
democrats are saying absolutely
anti-scientific things today
so are the media they're saying
absolutely anti-scientific things about
how
climate change works about the impact of
climate change about what can be done to
mitigate climate change
and they're really leaning on the slogan
science is real
in order to maintain that if you
disagree with anything they say it's
because you deny the science as we will
see that is a lie
right it's an over lie but by saying
science is real you can imply that your
opponents don't believe science is real
and that is why scientific american
today came out and endorsed joe biden
because
unlike they put up their law inside
unlike donald trump joe biden believes
that science is real
and then finally the sign concludes
water is life which is a weird thing
i mean that that actually is not
todological first of all water is not
actually
it is required for life i'm not sure who
is objecting to water
i'm a fan i like water too i don't even
know what the semantic overload in this
one
in this case is and finally injustice
anywhere is a threat to justice
everywhere
unless of course you are an individual
and you cross the social justice warrior
lines in which case you are to be judged
by group by group affiliation
right now the goal of the sign obviously
is to make you
is to elevate you to a higher moral plan
than your neighbors that is the goal of
the sign
and this has become the democratic party
slogan i mean basically you don't need a
platform anymore you just need the sign
because there are no solutions offered
there are no policy prescriptions
offered
nothing is offered here other than an
unearned sense of moral superiority
based on your denigrating feelings about
your neighbors copied and pasted into
this bizarre little sign
that makes you a better person because
you put it on your front lawn and that's
la the people
the homeless people can be still
suffering with mental illness and drug
addiction and pissing in the trash cans
directly across the street from you
illegal immigrants can still be living
in homeless shelters because you have
not come up with any solution
for how exactly to alleviate their
economic condition
the city of la can be falling into
complete and utter disrepair
wildfires can be plagued in the state of
california but so long as you have the
sign
you have participated in the solution
this is the democratic party slogan
so much of our politics is no longer
about finding solutions it used to be
ideally that politics was supposed to be
about finding common solutions to common
problems now
it is about naming problems that you
believe exist and if somebody has a
different solution
then you suggest that they don't believe
the problems exist at all right this is
the way our politics works
this is true on everything from policing
to climate change
even if somebody agrees with you that
there's a problem with police brutality
in some
police departments that's not enough
because if they disagree with your
solution which is to dismantle the
police that means they don't exist they
don't actually
understand the problem okay that that
political sign
is pretty much how our politics works
and so i have decided that uh i'm
i want to put up this sign in my front
yard in this house we believe if you put
up a lawn sign
filled with semantically overloaded
virtue signaling tautologies you're
you are an obnoxious ass that is that is
the lawn sign i think belongs on
everybody's front lawn
because frankly if you decide that it is
very important to you to feel good about
yourself by putting that lawn sign
on your uh on your lawn then uh i
i think people should have nothing to do
with you frankly i think it makes you
just by definition
incredibly incredibly obnoxious we'll
get to how that lawn sign has boiled
down
into the political debates of the day in
just one second because that really is
all that's happening here right somebody
put up a slogan so science is real
and now if you disagree with them on
their policies they'll just argue that
you think science is not real
okay science is real you guys are
getting the science wrong we'll get to
that in one second first
let us talk about the fact that it is
very important to protect your eyes from
the blue light that comes from your
favorite devices
my kids are online more for school i am
online more because there's just more
news happening it's an election cycle
and the entire world is entering an
apocalyptic period of doom
and that means that i'm spending an
awful lot of time in front of screens
well the blue light from the screens can
keep you awake
it can give you headaches and give you
eye strain this is why
you need felix gray glasses there are a
lot of blue light glasses on the market
but they are not all created equal
you can order online right now glasses
will ship directly to you
with a hard case and lens cloth included
try them 30 days risk-free
if your screens aren't easier on the
eyes you send them back for a full
refund they're really really durable
which
means a lot to me since my kids beat up
whatever i own go to felix
grayglasses.com for the absolute best
quality blue light filtering glasses on
the market
that's f-e-l-i-x g-r-a-y glasses dot com
slash ben felix grayglasses.com
shipping and returns totally free at
felix gray felix grayglasses.com
ben make sure that you can sleep better
that blue light can really screw you up
and not only that will give you the
headaches you won't feel very good this
is why you need felix gray glasses go
check them out right now
felix grayglasses.com shipping and
returns
are utterly and completely free so go
check that out right now felix
grayglasses.com alrighty so
this is the narrative of the day the
wildfires are raging in california the
air quality out there is horrendous
in fact california has become such a
hell hole that you can't go inside
because you might get covered
and you can't go outside because you
might die of smoke inhalation
so basically we're all just standing in
our doorways which is actually not bad i
mean if there's an earthquake i guess
we're all okay
that's pretty much all that that's where
we can be we can stand in the doorways
so the wildfires are happening president
trump visited california yesterday
and while president trump was in
california he met with gavin newsom and
some of the first responders and some of
the scientific advisors on handling
wildfires and while he was there
president trump
he said listen you know you can talk
about climate change all you want what
this really is about is bad forest
management
that happens to be exactly correct okay
it happens to be that federal policy has
prevented good forest management for a
long time in federal territory and state
policy in california has prevented
good policy when it comes to wildfires
for literally decades
we'll get to the details on that in just
a second well all of this
said by president trump who sort of
downplayed climate change as the factor
in wildfires which by the way makes some
sense
okay here's your choice today
scientifically speaking
you can argue that the wildfire that is
raging out of control in california and
oregon
is due to climate change or you can
argue that it is due to bad forest
management
or you can argue both okay
the the latter two options make some
sense right that it is due to bad forest
management
or that is bad forest management
combined with slight uptick
in average temperature in places like
california over the course of the last
century
what you cannot argue with any straight
phase is that climate change is the
actual reason for the wildfires
or for the increase in the territorial
spread of the wildfires you cannot make
that case that case is absurd in the
absence
of mentioning any of the federal and
state policy that has led to the
exacerbation of the tinder
that is available for these wildfires it
makes no sense at all
according to the environmental
protection agency the average
temperature in the state of california
over the past century has risen three
degrees fahrenheit
not 15 not 20 30 degrees fahrenheit that
makes for some drier brush
but do you think that the massive
wildfires that we are seeing today
is more a result of a three degree
fahrenheit increase over the course of
100 years
or do you think maybe it has more to do
with the fact that federal and state
policy have prohibited
any sort of controlled burning that
would have prevented
all of these tindered areas from
basically becoming a giant explosive
device
and which do you think it is well the
democrats have made their call
so gavin newsom meets with president
trump
and first he admits freely that we have
not actually done
our forest management justice like we've
actually blown the forest management
here was uh here is the
garbage governor gavin newsom who just
yesterday by the way was cutting videos
from bad areas of the california forest
he was literally sitting out there like
this is fine dog jiff and he's sitting
out there with his laptop and with like
some paper trying to explain that it was
it was the climate's fault right it was
the sun's fault it was carbon emissions
fault
it was not his fault he's been governor
of the state it's not his fault at all
well yesterday trump said you know your
bad forest management had something to
do with this and newsome was like well
that's kind of true
there's no question when you look past
this
decade and looking past almost a
thousand plus years
that we have not done justice on our
forest management i don't think anyone
disputes that
i want to acknowledge we have uh our u.s
forest representative here
the state of california your
administration just entered into
a first type commitment over the next 20
years to double
our vegetation management and forest
management i want to thank you for
supporting that effort
funding that effort we acknowledge our
role and responsibility to do more
in that space okay that should be the
end of that conversation right there
is that the state of california can
basically focus in on forest management
and alleviate this problem
over the course of the next few years
that would be the immediate solution to
this problem
instead gavin newsom then turns and
lectures trump on climate change and
this is what the democrats would like to
talk about
they don't want to talk about the
solutions that are at hand they don't
want to talk about the fact that if you
shut down
every industry in the united states
today all of them if trump had come in
and bombed into submission every
industry in the united states the day he
entered office
you know what still would have happened
this summer a giant wildfire
because guess what that is not how
climate change works if you cut off all
carbon emissions today
today it would not have made one iota of
difference
in terms of the wildfire damage that has
been done in california
as of 2020 in fact if we ceased all
carbon emissions today
today like all in the united states all
of them we would reduce global warming
over the course of the next 70 odd years
by 2100 okay by 2100 we would reduce
all global warming across the world if
we do if all emissions went to zero
today to zero
which is not a thing that's happening
okay if that were to happen
we would reduce global warming but i get
this 0.172
degrees celsius not 1.72 degrees
not 17 degrees 0.172 degrees celsius by
2100 if we ceased all carbon activities
today today okay that's if we
which is not even on the table if we
abided by the quote-unquote paris
agreement which is joe biden's big plan
right and barack obama's big plan
if we did all of that the estimate is
that if all nations did that if china
did it if india did it
if france did it if germany if all of
them did it
agreeing abiding by the limits in the
paris agreement would lower
climate change by the end of the century
by 0.17 degrees celsius
for all nations for all nations because
it turns out that the paris agreement
gives you a little bit more time than
like shut down all industry today and
still
you would end up with a 0.17 degrees
celsius reduction
in the climate increase by 2100
so as we will see the solutions that are
being posited by
the democrats have nothing to do with
the reality of the forest fires in
california if you actually want to solve
the forest fires in california you have
to do what human beings have
historically
been extremely good at doing adapting
you have to create new technologies
you have to take policies that make
sense when it comes to hurricanes you
have to build new sea walls
you have to stop building things
directly in the path of hurricanes right
there are things that we can do
that mitigate damage in the immediate
term but democrats don't want to talk
about any of that the media don't want
to talk about any of that instead
they just want to say that trump is a
climate denier
now you may say to yourself yes but that
doesn't change any of the policy even if
trump denies climate change that doesn't
change anything that's going on right
now right
but according to democrats in a
paganistic fashion if trump were to
mouth
climate change is the most important
thing that has ever happened then the
oceans would begin to slow the rise of
the oceans would begin to slow like
barack obama said
in his iowa victory speech back in 2008
if only we would accept that climate
change is responsible for every ill
right we don't have to pose a solution
because there are no actual
obvious solutions to what's happening
right now except for the ones that are
on the ground when it comes to climate
change there are no obvious
and actual solutions that are available
when that hap
but if you mouth the words if you if you
put up that lawn sign
just in the universe then presumably all
of this will end
this is the pitch the democrats are
making that is an anti-scientific pitch
that is a pagan ridiculous
non-provable non-verifiable
anti-evidentiary pitch
okay so that is the direction in which
avenue summit was pushing so we'll get
to gavin newsom and his idiocy in just
one second avoiding responsibility by
citing global climate change
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact
that the second amendment is really
important these days why well you gotta
protect your rights but you also have to
protect yourself
there is a major crime wave happening in
cities across the united states
i'm getting letters from people who have
been accosted on streets people who have
been mugged people have been beaten up
and increasingly there is the threat
that
criminals are going to come into your
area right these are these are all real
concerns these are not fake concerns
having a gun to protect yourself is a
very very smart thing to do and that is
why i trust the uscca not merely
because they can help you get informed
about your gun but also because they'll
provide you legal defense
in case god forbid you have to use your
gun correctly in self-defense that is
not a guarantee
that the authorities aren't going to
come after you anyway as we've seen
repeatedly now
in this day and age you need a gun to
protect yourself and your family and you
need to know how to use it and what you
can legally do
get your 100 free copy of the complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
from the united states concealed carry
association it is 164 pages it comes
with the bonus audio version so you can
listen whenever you want just text
shapiro to 87
222 you'll get instant access and a
chance to win a thousand bucks
so you can buy a gun to protect your
family text shapiro to 87 222
right now again a chance to win a gun
which is great if you're a law abiding
citizen and
you get instant access to that complete
concealed carry and family
defense guide from the u.s concealed
carry association they help you with the
information you need
and self-defense information and
protection you want go check them out
right now the uscca just text shapiro to
87 222 to get started get instant access
to that guide and a chance to win a
thousand bucks
so you can buy a gun and to protect your
family tech shapiro to 87
222 right now okay so first gavin newsom
admits freely
that they've completely botched their
forest management like completely
botched it
then gavin newsom turns and lectures
trump on climate change
and this has become the theme of the day
trump hates science
trump hates now do i think that donald
trump knows the first thing about
science
no i really like i i see no evidence
that donald trump sits around in his
spare time reading pop science books
i don't think he subscribes to
scientific american i don't think that's
his thing
but let's say that trump believed
wholeheartedly in the
realities and threats of climate change
would that mean that the wildfires
wouldn't have just occurred
no we had wildfires all throughout the
obama administration
this is not how science works science
doesn't work by you shouting you believe
in it
like a religious totem at the top of
your lungs and then the universe leaves
you alone
like you stand in the face of a
hurricane you go climate change is real
and then the hurricane's like well i
guess we're done here i guess i'm just
gonna move right out to sea
you said climate change is real i guess
we're finished here and guess what
all of your idiotic policies about
building
energy-efficient houses and all of this
stuff it is not calibrated to actually
stop climate change
it is not okay the solutions that are
put forth by joe biden will not
they will not alleviate climate change
in any serious way by the end of the
century
if we actually care about climate change
over time what we are going to need to
do
is pour money into making energy
efficient
not energy efficient houses into making
more sources of energy efficiency like
new technologies
human beings are very good at technology
there are two things basically that
human beings can do about climate change
one is we can pour money into r d such
that we can create
more efficient sources of energy okay
not the ones that we're currently
talking about not stupid windmills if
your solution to climate change right
now like the forest is burning build a
windmill bob
that's not that's not a solution it's
not even close to a solution
the fact is that california two weeks
ago was experiencing a heat wave
and rolling brown outs because we had
decided to decommission our nuclear
facilities
and also move away from natural gas and
toward quote unquote green
energy solutions so people instead were
plotting from the heat
so if you actually want to do this what
you need to do is develop technologies
that are actually
economically efficient and that people
can opt for and there are some of that
right i mean
people are now driving electric cars
more than ever right that's a good thing
and two we can engage in adaptation and
that means things like perhaps
geoengineering
it means that we have to build more sea
walls it means better infrastructure it
means don't build directly next to a
wildfire area
it means you have to take measures like
controlled burns right these are all
practical things we can do democrats
don't talk about any of those things
instead
they talk about these broad-scale
quote-unquote ideas
for curbing climate change that when
when actually evaluated costs trillions
of dollars and don't accomplish what
they're seeking to accomplish but it's
not about that
understand it's about the lawn sign it's
about science is real so here is
gavin newsom shouting at trump science
is real then the media going it's true
science
is real and don and donald trump doesn't
believe in science
here's gavin newsom this idiotic kendall
here he goes
something's happened to the plumbing of
the world and we come from a perspective
humbly where we submit the science
in and observed evidence is self-evident
uh that climate change is real and that
is exacerbating this and so
i think there's an area of at least
commonality on vegetation forest
management
uh but please respect and i know you do
uh the difference of opinion
out here as it relates to this
fundamental issue on the issue of
climate change
okay but that fundamental issue is not a
fundamental issue i mean who cares what
trump believes about quote unquote
climate change
why why does that matter the question is
the policies is he blocking a policy
that would have stopped the fire
is he stop is he cutting the forest
management
like what what's the notice well notice
what
gavin newsom does there he says we can
agree on the solutions actually we can
grant that but do you agree that science
is real
do you agree with my lawn sign right
here that has made no difference in
alleviating wildfires in california for
the past several decades
do you and it's actually exacerbated do
you agree with my lawn sign
sir if you don't agree with my lawn sign
that means you're bad
because my lawn sign is a lawn sign joe
biden did this routine yesterday as well
and this was joe biden's big speech so
he emerged from the basement right every
few days he emerges like the groundhog
to determine whether there are further
days of election so he emerged
from the basement uh and he stood in a
wheat field
which was kind of weird i'm not sure
that even joe biden knew where he was
he stood in a wheat field and he mumbled
some words and then he went back down
into the basement without taking
questions which is his way
of running a campaign so far it's been
successful because
president trump is constantly stepping
on rakes but let's not pretend that joe
biden is running a masterful campaign
he's not even walking a masterful
campaign he is hobbling at best a
masterful campaign
he's hobbling he's crawling a masterful
campaign
we'll get to joe biden and his science
is real speech
or as he might put it his sciences
around
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
you may be looking around right now and
thinking to yourself
hey you know i might need some life
insurance
and the reason i might need some life
insurance is because i mean things are
crazy right now
well there is good news you can still
shop for life insurance you might be
thinking to yourself can i still get
life insurance the answer is yes
if you have loved ones depending on your
income you probably should right now you
could say 1500
or more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for a decade or more those
savings really do start to add up so
what exactly is policy genius it's an
insurance marketplace it's built
and backed by a team of industry experts
and here's how it works step one head on
over to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
step two you can apply for your lowest
price step three the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape
policy genius works for you not the
insurance company so if you hit any
speed bumps during the application
process
they will take care of everything they
even have policies that allow eligible
customers to skip the in-person medical
exam
and do it over the phone so if you need
life insurance head on over to
policygenius.com
right now to get started you could say
1500 bucks or more a year by comparing
quotes on their marketplace policy
genius it's important to have the right
life insurance
this is an important thing to do if
you're a responsible human who wants to
take care of your family
policygenius.com go check them out right
now okay so
joe biden gives his speech in the middle
of a wheat field
and he just this is just sheer lawn sign
demagoguery lawn signed politics at its
best joe biden as lawn sign
so the speech is about eight minutes
this is what he's been doing right he
just goes to a location and then he
speaks for eight minutes and then he
goes back in the basement
so here's groundhog joe emerging to talk
about the crises america is facing now
we're gonna go through the crisis he's
talking about here as it turns out he
mentions four crises that you're about
to hear for
three of them are the faults of
democratic policy here is joe biden
as a nation we face one of the most
difficult moments
in our history in my view four historic
crises all
at the same time the worst pandemic
in 100 years that's already killed
nearly 200 000 people in county
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
has cost tens of millions of american
jobs
and counting emboldened white supremacy
unseen since the 60s and a reckoning
on race that's long overdue
and undeniable acceleration of the
punishing reality
of climate change on our planet
and our people on the lives and
livelihoods
which i'd like to talk about now okay so
he mentions four crises
three of them are the faults of
democratic policy okay so he mentions
the pandemic not gonna blame that on
democrats democrats will blame that on
trump because they don't know anything
about science
okay it turns out that science means
that the virus has gone everywhere and
it's killed tons of people everywhere as
it turns out
donald trump didn't personally infect
everybody in new york that is
anti-science
today andrew cuomo idiot governor of new
york tweeted out science knows
you know what science knows that it's a
terrible idea to ship coveted positive
elderly folks
back into nursing homes and kill 11 000
of them it turns out that's a really
crappy policy andrew cuomo
okay but joe biden names four crisis one
is the
is the pandemic the second is the worst
economic crisis since the great
depression
okay that is largely due to misbegotten
lockdown policies that have prevented
economies from recovering
you know half the people who are
currently claiming unemployment live in
the state of california
half of them really of the 14 million
people who are currently claiming
unemployment
half of them live in the state of
california because california is still
completely locked down
now you could have a lockdown policy
that alleviates at certain points you
could have people going back to school
right you could have all these things
but misbegotten lockdown policy has made
the economic crisis significantly worse
than it has to be
if you don't believe me just check the
difference between the lockdown states
and the non-lockdown states in terms of
how they are doing
in unemployment rate and economic
recovery there's a vast difference
the third crisis is what he calls
emboldened white supremacy unseen since
the 60s
and a reckoning on race that's long
overdue so what we're watching in the
real world here is not quote unquote
emboldened white supremacy
spreading across the nation and
resulting in riots across the country in
major cities
we're not watching white supremacists
shoot cops
white supremacy is a threat i know i've
been one of their main targets
okay the the fbi arrested a white
supremacist for targeting my family
just last year believe you me i'm pretty
hard on the white supremacist
but if we are talking about what we are
watching in real time right now it is
not an overdue reckoning on race
it is rioters and looters going around
in major cities claiming that the police
are systemically racist backed by the
democratic party and committing crimes
and then members of the biden campaign
bailing them out of jail that is what we
are watching right now
so that would be the fault of the
democratic party if you're watching
a bunch of people rioting in chicago la
dc new york
portland seattle kenosha and your first
response is
that's in bold and white supremacy
that's because you are blind or a
okay and finally he says an undeniable
acceleration of the punishing reality of
climate change on our planet weird
because climate change
is a long-term prospect it is a
long-term thing
it does have real world consequences and
i believe
that it is caused mostly by man-made
emissions that does not mean the
solutions that democrats are proposing
are in any way realistic or useful now i
tend to believe
as the e as the nobel prize winner in
economics
who writes specifically on the cost of
climate change policies and solutions
william nordhaus writes
that one of the things you have to do is
balance the future growth of the world
economy
against any measures that you take today
that could dampen that growth
in other words you do have to allow a
certain amount of climate change to
happen
because it is counterproductive to do
otherwise if you shut down the entire
world industry
in order to stop climate change today
first of all it wouldn't occur you
wouldn't
stop it you might alleviate it like that
much a very very small amount
okay and also you would destroy all of
the economic
growth that would allow for adaptation
and better living conditions because as
it turns out you know it's a great
protector against climate change
being wealthy it really is it's quite
good
there's a reason why hurricanes when
they hit the united states they can be
devastating not on the same order of
devastation as if they hit haiti
the fact is that living in a corrugated
iron shack
is much worse in terms of what you can
do to fight climate change
on a personal level than living in an
air-conditioned climate-controlled house
wealth is an actual really important
thing i know people in the first world
tend to forget about this but there are
lots of people who don't live in nice
houses
and even nice apartments in any
the uh case are three crises and and
when it comes to the the impacts of
climate change democrats have militated
against actual adapted adaptive
solutions right they're shutting down
nuclear power plants
they're not allowing for the the clear
burning of particular areas that would
that would stop
wildfires from from going so crazy they
are continuing to facilitate the
rebuilding
in areas that are most liable to to be
damaged by hurricanes like
all of this is bad democratic policy so
three of those four crises have been
exacerbated by democratic policies
and then biden continues and he talks
about wildfires he says wildfires don't
skip towns right
wildfires don't care whether you're a
republican or a democrat
okay that's true but you know what is
also true
you can stop the wildfires from hitting
towns if you burn
areas in controlled fashion close to
populated areas
so that they don't eat the towns okay
but but democrats won't do any of that
wildfires don't skip towns that voted a
certain way
the impacts of climate change don't pick
and choose
that's because it's not a partisan
phenomenon
it's science and our response should be
the same
grounded in science science science and
if he says science and science over and
over climate change stops and wildfire
management never has to be undertaken
he can just say science he puts up the
lawn sign and magically everything gets
better
when you get more lawn sign speeches on
climate change from
joe biden in just one second then we'll
talk about the actual policy changes
that could be made but everybody is
ignoring i mean
it's just it's it's so irritating on a
primal level to me i mean
seriously seriously irritating on a
primal level that democrats don't want
to talk about solutions when it comes to
how we
adapt and mitigate climate change
instead all they want to do all day long
is just shout that you don't agree with
science and then we're supposed to be
like oh yes the party that agrees
the party that believes that a man can
be a woman and a woman can be a man
the party that believes that donald
trump directly causes hurricanes
the party that believes that if a
vaccine is developed by donald trump's
fda you shouldn't take it because donald
trump has personally poisoned the thing
and the party that also believes that
babies in the womb are not babies they
are mere clusters of cells that is the
party of science
spare me we'll get to more of joe biden
and science
in just one second first let's talk
about how there has never been a better
time
really to sign up for that online
university campuses are closed
and why not pick some classes that are
actually going to teach you something as
opposed to the nonsense that you would
learn
at some of the major universities anyway
when you think of your future you think
of your goals
where you want to be substitute dreams
for goals suddenly planning your future
is bigger
because people don't have small dreams
dream bigger with ashford university and
get a degree
from ashford they offer online
bachelor's and master's degree programs
allowing you to learn on a convenient
and flexible schedule at ashford expert
faculty teaches you real world skills
from real world experience in online
classes built for life's twists and
turns you can learn from home
or wherever you feel comfortable you can
pursue a degree in one of ashford's 60
plus programs like business
administration
healthcare administration and psychology
with 24 7 access to your classroom daily
support and financial aid available
ashford gives you the tools you need to
go from dreaming to doing
so stop putting off your education now
is a great time to learn at home go to
ashford.edu
no fee to apply or standardized testing
required to enroll that's ashford.edu
and make your resume better today now's
a great time to burnish that resume
ashford.edu
ben not all programs available in
allstate ashford.edu
go check them out alrighty so tonight
9pm eastern 6 pm pacific president trump
is
taking part in a town hall aired by abc
news two days before joe biden's own
town hall on cnn he said he's too busy
to do one with abc news
daily wire will be guiding you through
this with another special all-access
live you can watch the town hall with
you
over at dailywire.com tonight at 8 45 pm
eastern 5 4 5 45 pm pacific the excrebel
michael moles will stream the town hall
complete with live commentary you can
watch the stream on dailywire.com
youtube or facebook
you can only interact with michael
however if you're an all access member
so
be sure to head on over to dailywear.com
join the live chat with michael
during the town hall and afterward
finally we'll have the question answered
as to whether he is in fact the press
secretary for joe biden they look
exactly the same and i've never seen
both of them
in the same place at the same time only
all access members get to join these all
access live sessions
where one of the daily wire hosts hops
on every night to chat with you both in
live stream
and in the comments all access
membership also features not one but two
leftist years tumblers with your
membership as well as early and
sometimes exclusive access to new
delaware products so
head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
right now to get 15
off all access with coupon code watch
that is dailywire.com with coupon code
watch to get 15 off your membership
lastly if you watch this podcast on
youtube know this
september 28th it's coming up like right
now it will be moving
this podcast from the daily wire channel
to be available exclusively on my
youtube channel
ben shapiro so you need to go to youtube
and you search ben shapiro and then you
find the ben shapiro channel and
subscribe there that's the only way
you're going to continue to get my
podcast
and be alerted to it get the link in the
description below that's also the
easiest way right literally just look in
the description below pause it right now
click on that link subscribe i'm also
making a lot of new content you can only
find on my channel
so you should go subscribe just to that
channel subscribe to my youtube channel
ben shapiro ring the bell to make sure
you never miss out on a new video
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
okay so joe biden continues with his
science's real speech again he offers no
solutions that are of any practical
effect
he just blabbers on about how climate
change is real and then he dares donald
trump to say climate change isn't real
so he can have a fight on that
particular topic and no solutions get
done which is like the dumbest form of
this conversation ever
so here is joe biden literally literally
dismissing
the actual solutions to forest fires and
wildfires
because science is real
the west is literally on fire
and he blames the people whose homes and
communities
are burning he says quote you got to
clean your floors you got to clean your
forest
is literally the solution literally the
solution
is forest and veg and vegetate and um
vegetation management
that's exactly what gavin newsom the
governor of california said directly to
trump right
but apparently it's bad if trump says it
because science because science
okay and then we go into full dennis
quaid in day after tomorrow mode with
joe biden
he says you know what's actually
threatening our suburbs not people who
are committing crimes
not rampant homelessness not a federal
attempt to
redo how your community is built by
putting
giant publicly sponsored apartment
complexes directly next to your house
none of that what's actually threatening
the suburbs is climate change
now again climate change is a long-term
threat to certain
areas of american life human beings have
an enormous capacity to adapt we will
have better technology and we'll be a
lot richer in 100 years than we are
right now
there are certain things that we can do
i've mentioned many of them already but
according to joe biden if donald trump
is reelected president
the wrath of khan will emerge mother
nature will take her revenge
and the suburbs will burn not because of
his supporters burning the suburbs which
is what's been happening but because
the climate will get angry at you the
climate like a nasty vengeful god
will come down from on high and smite
you if donald trump is re-elected
here is pagan joe biden
meanwhile donald trump warns that
integration is threatening our suburbs
it's ridiculous but you know what is
actually threatening our suburbs
wildfires are burning the suburbs in the
west floods are wiping out suburban
neighborhoods in the midwest
hurricanes are imperiling suburban life
along our coast
if we have four more years of trump's
climate denial how many suburbs will be
burned
in wildfires how many suburban
neighborhoods will have been flooded out
how many suburbs will have been blown
away
in superstorms if you give a climate
arsonist
four more years in the white house why
would anyone be surprised if we have
more
america blaze if you give a climate
denier four more years in the white
house
why would anyone be surprised when more
of america is underwater
that is not how climate change works
that's seriously not how climate change
works
that if donald trump is elected for four
more years then
america will burn and the entire
coastline will be under like what in the
world is he talking about
again if we shut down every industry in
the united states
today if all carbon emissions shut down
today
if we came and siphoned the gas out of
your car today
we would lower the global climate on
planet earth by 0.172 degrees celsius by
what in the actual f is he talking about
this stupid idiot
but science is real guys that pagan crap
that he just told you that if donald
trump is re-elected then
cities will burn and the and the waters
will emerge and swamp your city but
whereas if you like
joe biden and obviously everything
changes weird because i was promised the
same thing by barack obama that was the
moment when the seas were
didn't i mean we elected him right
wasn't that the moment when the seas
were going to begin for a seed
and then that didn't happen because it
turns out that's not the way any of this
works
but don't worry science and that is joe
biden's final pitch science science
we need science here is joe biden on
science
we need a president respect science who
understands
that the damage from climate change is
already here
unless we take urgent action
will soon be more catastrophic
a president who recognizes understands
and
cares that americans are dying
which makes president trump's climate
denialism
his disdain for science and facts all
the more unconscionable
i mean joe biden's disdain for
articulable english
is obvious from that clip but we need a
president it's all about the feelings
it's all about the feelings of science
he's got the lawn sign right there
science is real i mean he's saying it so
why don't you believe him science is
real
well we didn't we need a president who's
going to say science is real over and
over and over sure won't accomplish
anything but he's got the lawn sign gang
the lawn sign is all that matters
that's all that matters the lawn sign
my favorite is then he said that he has
concrete actionable
programs okay and this is pretty
hilarious so so his plan
is that we are going to get to net zero
emissions by no later than 2050
by 2050. okay again quick note
greta thuneberg who goes around talking
about how the adults they don't believe
us they don't believe that it's urgent
it's so urgent
how happy you think she's gonna be with
joe biden saying that we're gonna get to
net zero by 2050
which is last i checked 30 years from
now
yeah yeah joe biden's gonna save the
world guys science is real
good good good job joe good excellent
excellent job
by the way i have a policy that could
really stop a lot of wildfires here's
here's a policy it's really easy
actually it doesn't have to do with
forest management
you ready here's the policy arrest
people commit arson
and then keep them in jail i mention
this policy because here is breaking
news from the new york post quote
an oregon man was charged with using a
molotov cocktail to start a brush blaze
in the wildfire devastated state
and then busted again just six hours
later for allegedly going back and
starting six more cops said
well weird because i thought he was
arrested the first time so how did he
get out of jail to start six more fires
domingo lopez jr 45 was first arrested
sunday afternoon after witnesses told
cops he started a fire on the grassy
edge of a portland freeway with an
incendiary device made out of a plastic
bottle with a wick
he admitted starting the blaze which was
extinguished without any injuries or
property damage he was booked into jail
at 6 45 pm sunday
on charges of reckless burning and
second-degree disorderly conduct
then because portland is portland he was
released on his own recognizance later
that night
he was found walking along the edge of
the same highway just after 3 30 a.m
monday as cops joined fire crews to
investigate reports of six more fires
portland police said
this time he appeared to start the fires
with a lighter which was seized as
evidence
luckily all the fires were caught early
no one was injured no structures were
burned said the police
so i mean here's a good way to to stop
some of these fires is to keep people in
jail who commit arson
also you know would be a great way to
stop fires to mitigate the homeless
problem in the state of california
i had uh i had a a kind of
evening dinner with some firefighters
out here in la
in the last couple of weeks and they
were saying to me that half of the
fire calls they get are homeless people
setting fires either accidentally or on
purpose
so good news is that california has
decided to basically look the other way
on the homeless problem
other things that we could do to prevent
all of these wildfires from from getting
wars
here here are a few other things that we
could do we could mitigate
some of the federal regulations
governing all of this reason magazine
says the regulatory requirements one
must meet before starting a controlled
burn
are complex and lengthy we need more
controlled burns because otherwise you
just basically have these giant
tinderboxes
especially since the 1960s efforts to
extinguish all fires even natural
low-impact forest fires that serve as
nature's equivalent of a controlled burn
have made forests more susceptible to
larger fires and have made control burns
more and more necessary
according to jonathan wood attorney with
the pacific legal foundation adjunct
fellow with the property and environment
research center
the national environmental policy act
requires quote a couple thousand page
document
analyzing every single conceivable
impacts the environment that a control
burn plan might have
this is a public process that often
results in litigation what you'll often
find says what is that there are
projects which have been extremely well
vetted
that have been years in the work there
will be a 5 000 page document no one
could conceivably read because it's so
long and complicated then the project
will be put on hold
because some special interest group
filed a lawsuit from 1999 to 2017
an average of 13 000 acres of california
were subjected to controlled burns
every year in february 2020 nature
sustainability its magazine published a
report arguing california needs to burn
20 million acres of forest in order to
restore forest health
so they burned 13 000 acres a year in
california
from 1999 to 2017. we now need to burn
20 million acres of forest
that's the fault of climate change not
bad policy
also the clean erect of 1990 creates an
obstacle because the law treats the
smoke from a controlled prescribed burn
as a pollutant that has to be analyzed
they don't do the same from a wildfire
we can see the smoke right now from the
wildfire
and this goes back decades president
clinton
in his closing days in office january
5th 2001 new york times
in the biggest land conservation act in
decades president clinton will approve
an order on friday putting nearly a
third of the national forest land
permanently off-limits to road building
and logging
so the idea there is that people were
clear-cutting and not replacing the
trees that's not true but if you don't
get rid of old wood one of the things
that happens that it tends to burn
okay joe biden continues however to
shout science is real so that means he's
good
and that we we know he's good it doesn't
matter that
this is very much a political problem
and it doesn't matter that a lot of what
biden is saying is
patently anti-scientific the increased
damage from hurricanes for example is
not due to the increased activity of
hurricanes there has been no increase
in number of hurricanes and there has
been an increase
in some cases of the intensity of
hurricanes perhaps because of warm water
layers at the top of the ocean
but the real reason you've seen
increased damage is not because the
hurricanes are worse it's because more
and more people have built stuff in the
way of the hurricanes
right the target area is now larger
it doesn't matter he believes in science
and the media they're going to
they're going to repeat this until it's
true repeat until it's true
here is the headline from the new york
times which is basically just the pr
wing
for the democratic party at this point
this is the lead headline at the new
york times you ready for this
here's the new york times headline very
objective newsifying journalism
all over the place the journalism
getting sticky and weird all over all
over the place here's the new york times
getting sticky and word with joe biden
trump scorns science as fires rage biden
calls trump climate arsonist
oh is that is that what's happening
trump's score in science is the big
story
not california's forest mismanagement
causes massive wildfires not every blue
state on the coast has botched this
thing they're all blue states by the way
ain't no red states
on the west coast of the united states
not climate change has mildly
exacerbated
what is really a forest management
problem which is a far more accurate
statement again the climate in
california has warmed a grand total of
three degrees fahrenheit
over the past hundred years according to
the epa nope
the headline is trump's score in science
uh they've got the bumper sticker don't
they
and now scientific american is putting
out its own endorsement of joe biden
they've never backed a presidential
candidate in 175 years
but now because all things must be
political scientific american is going
to be political too
scientific american has issued an
endorsement because science
because science what is their very
sciency case for why joe biden
ought to be president the evidence and
the science as scientific american
show that donald trump has badly damaged
the us and its people because he rejects
evidence and science
the most devastating example is is his
dishonest and inept response
to the coveted 19 pandemic which has
cost
more than a hundred thousand ninety
thousand americans their lives by the
middle
of september he has also attacked
environmental protections medical care
and the researchers and public science
agencies that helped this country
prepare for its greatest challenges
that is why we urge you to vote for joe
biden who is offering fact-based plans
to protect our health our economy and
our environment he has literally offered
no coveted planet to present any way
from the trump administration plan
he has done nothing to protect the
economy he's calling for renewed
lockdowns which destroy the economy
and as far as the environment he just
out he shouts climate is real
and then endorses ridiculous green new
deals that are never going to be
implemented
by the way you know it's anti-science
claiming that donald trump is
responsible for the 190 000 american
deaths
from covet that is anti-science if it's
really the politicians who are
responsible for the deaths
then i look forward to scientific
american endorsing andrew cuomo's
opponent in
new york the fact that scientific
american
is now doing this routine it is uh is
pretty
impressive stuff really really
simplistic
anti-evidence absurd
again they're now blaming the governors
in florida arizona and texas
for resisting complete lockdowns they're
saying science dictates the lockdown
science does not dictate the lockdowns
again the lockdowns were meant
to mitigate the infection rates that
they didn't overwhelm the hospital
system they were never meant as a way to
crush the virus
it has not crushed the fighters anywhere
we're seeing upticks in europe every
single country except for wait for it
sweden why
because they didn't lock down yeah but
don't worry the scientific americans
have they have
their uh have their endorsement
super super scientific really really
scientific stuff
it's just ridiculous but you know again
the the narrative is out there and the
narrative is all you have to do is say
science is real and it doesn't matter
how bad you are at your job this is why
the new york times
has a massive interview with jerry brown
jerry brown was governor of the state of
california from both 1975 to 1983
and 2011 to 2019 what did he do to
mitigate the wildfires
oh that's right nothing zero things but
don't worry
he says climate change is real so the
new york times gives him
the the s the tongue slathering
treatment
in their pages and by the way i do love
this this is pretty spectacular
so he says you might say we are getting
out of here we're going someplace else
if you're a californian
he says no there are going to be
problems everywhere in the united states
this is the new normal
it's been predicted it's happening this
is part of the new long-term experience
tell me where are you going to go
what's your alternative canada you're
going to go to places like iowa where
you have tornadoes
well no people are fleeing california
because of mismanagement
they are leaving california because this
place is run like crap
worth noting governor jerry brown vetoed
a measure
to create a california fire map and took
nine years to develop the fire map
seven of those years were during jerry
brown's term in office but the good news
is the new york times says he believes
in science
okay meanwhile we are watching as the
cops are blamed for literally every bad
thing in america
by the democratic left in the press
which is always exciting news
according to the chicago police
superintendent emily zanati reporting
over at daily wire
attacks on officers are up five times
over previous years
last week 72 people were shot and
wounded in chicago 18 people were killed
that's a slight increase over 2019.
overall though murders and shootings are
each up 52 over the last year according
to the chicago police department's
official statistics and the tax on
police officers are up five times over
previous years amid a spike in shootings
that has left
the city reeling fox news reports dozens
of police
chicago police officers have been shot
or shot at so far this year including as
recently as this weekend
when the illinois city saw 35 shootings
and at least 10 murders through sunday
of the 65 chicago police officers who
have been shot at 10 have been struck
according to the chicago police
superintendent who is in fact the black
man david o'brown
he said that during monday morning's
press conference he says this is not a
comparable year
this is five times any previous year
that anyone can recall in the city
okay so the latest headline of the day
and how the cops are bad
is that um if cops have their uh
are driving their car and are trying to
get to a reported crime and people
block the car or jump on the car or
start trying to
break into the car the cops are just
supposed to sit there this narrative was
promoted yesterday in sacramento so a
bunch of black lives matter protesters
and antifa members presumably mostly
white of course because this is a bunch
of dispossessed white jackasses
they're standing out in the streets of
sacramento a police officer has his
lights on he is trying to get to some
reported crime
and they decide that they are going to
obstruct one of these morons jumps on
the front hood of the car now here is my
basic rule
okay here's my basic rule if you jump on
the front hood
of a vehicle that is on what happens
next is on you
if you jump on the front hood of a car
that is attempting to go somewhere
what happens next is your fault i feel
like this should be relatively
uncontroversial
the fact that it is controversial means
that you just expect police officers
to basically just be field test dummies
right they're crash test dummies from
the old commercials they're supposed to
just absorb
all the blows and never defend
themselves and never get out of harm's
way
okay so here is what happens a an idiot
jumps on the front of a cop car
and uh and the cop decides that he is
not in fact going to sit around
and have his car broken into and abused
and he is not going to be put a threat
and so he drives off and uh boom we will
catch you later gang
and then people start screaming and oh
my god what's happened what's happened
oh no it's so
okay it's not so terrible that's not
terrible
end of story i have nothing else to say
on that that cop didn't do anything
wrong
and the cops are trying to go somewhere
to answer a crime you surround the cop
cars and by the way this is the day
after or two days after
two cops were nearly murdered in an
assassination attempt in compton when
someone walked up to the driver's side
window or to the passenger side window
and and shot two of the cops directly in
the head okay so
um if i'm that cop i'm keeping on going
too and you should too
we've seen this over and over by the way
yeah this has been happening at blm
protest for months
that there will be civilians not just
cops civilians who are attempting to get
through an area
and then blm protesters will surround
the car and start pounding on the car
and people will hit the gas to get the
hell out of there because they're afraid
of what's going to happen
and then the blm protesters in the media
are like how could somebody do that
if you jump in front of a moving vehicle
that's your fault
if you jump on the hood of a moving
vehicle that is your fault if you
attempt to obstruct people
in their ability to exercise their basic
right to use the roads for which they
pay
taxes then that's your fault so
cops are always expected to uh to absorb
all forms of harm which is why by the
way you've seen
the the blm movement riot over cases in
which the cop
obviously exercised self-defense in
which the suspect was coming at them
with a knife right that's what happened
in lancaster pennsylvania
there was a riot in lancaster after a
cop shot a man who was charging him with
a knife
and cops are not crash test dummies cops
are human beings
who stand between you and the worst that
america has to offer
and meanwhile i am enjoying the
full-scale media defenses now so the
media have to somehow come up with a
defense for the fact that so many of
these protests have turned violent
they've turned into looting
and so it's turned into a right-wing
myth right this is the way it is
conservatives pounds
every time a blm protest turns into
rioting and looting or any time
people from blm are literally on tape
attempting to
break into a hospital or obstruct any
ambulance or are shouting in glee when
cops get shot
and we have to pretend that they are
completely unassociated with the blm
movement
if you ever doubt media bias just think
about the idea that if there were ever a
tea party
one tea party event where one person had
gotten hurt
okay a tea party event where a person
had gotten hurt the media
would immediately impute that not only
to the entire tea party but to every
republican legislator in america
we had an entire movement in the early
obama administration called occupy wall
street where people were
sitting in parks and people were getting
raped in parks and crime was taking
place and the media was like yes but
their cause is just
we saw in the last couple of months an
independent republic
of chaz chop set up in the middle of
seattle and the media were like oh it's
like a street fair until two people got
shot to death
and the cops were barred from coming in
and so now don lemon is doing the heavy
lifting he says
you know how can you conflate this
police ambush that happened in l.a with
the protests i'm not conflating with the
protests
most of the protesters are not murderers
most of the protesters that i've seen
because there are some 15 million of
them are not rioters and looters in fact
i think most of the protesters don't
even understand what the hell they are
protesting for or against
i think they just think that they're
protesting and saying racism is bad
which okay
sure racism of course is bad but like in
the classical definition
nonetheless candy tear down the system
definition okay but don lemon because
he has to come up with a reason why the
protests keep randomly devolving into
bad things
he has to say oh this is a republicans
pounce case here is don lemon being very
republican's pouncey
i think we should be very clear because
i hear people conflating it
to the protests or that we don't know
that yet
we don't know that but what we do know
is something horrible happened
and there should be no excuse made for
it and um
and i i hope these officers get better
uh
my heart and my thoughts go out to their
families and also to the members
of the department but there's no excuse
for that kind of violence
okay so we have no evidence that it's
conflated with the protest weird because
you'll conflate every single bad thing
that happens in the united states with
something donald trump said
strange strange and then abc sunny
hostin on the view
a repository of all human stupidity she
she says that the blm protest movement
is being
being violent that's a false narrative
it's a false narrative according to a
widespread study
of all of the blm protests across the
country some seven percent of them
dissolved into violence and rioting and
looting which is like 500 different
events
evolving into violence and rioting and
looting here's sunny haas it's all a
myth never happened
according to a new fox news poll more
voters classify blm
unrest as riots rather than protests and
that is scary because that's feeding
into this narrative
that the trump campaign has been putting
out there and if you really look at the
facts
93 percent 93 of protests
are non-violent and so this is
manufactured by the trump campaign and i
just wish
that people understood that and knew
that and just looked up the real facts
about protests in this country
okay on that on the table in front of me
thought experiment on the table in front
of me are 100 glasses of lemonade
93 of them have no poison in them
does this seem like a good deal to you
are you gonna take a drink how do you
feel about that
also what if some of those glasses of
lemonade turned into
glass of lemonade with poison in them
would you would you take a drink because
you don't know which is which
this is just it's such absurdity the
media's willingness to overlook
the actual violence and rioting and
looting they did the same thing in 2016
when when blm
had this this moment again in 2016 and
six dallas police officers were murdered
in dallas by a blm member a
self-proclaimed blm member and i was
like well he has nothing to do with the
protest
okay well um you can distinguish the
rioters and the protests and looters by
identifying the crime but if you're
talking about the underlying ideology
and what it pushes
you got a problem you got a problem well
i guess we're not going to hear about
incendiary rhetoric
also on cnn we're not going to hear
about incendiary rhetoric here is
a retired la police department sergeant
named sheryl dorsey appearing as a cnn
guest and literally making excuses
i mean this is amazing there's a guest
on cnn making excuses for the attempted
assassination of two police officers in
california
my first reaction was sadness because
listen there's a lot of chatter on
social media
about an eye for an eye we know that
there are reports of
internal gangs within the compton
sheriff department particularly they
refer to themselves as the executioner
and so i wondered aloud if this wasn't
maybe retaliation
for the failure to hold officers
accountable not only in the compton
sheriff's department
but uh nationally when we see instances
of officers using deadly force as a
first resort rather than a last resort
you know it's bad that it happened but
maybe it was just retaliation for a lack
of accountability okay that is a full-on
justification
of violence against police officers
don't tell me that there's an
ideological separation when i'm not
seeing the ideological separation
i'm not if you want to say that that
violence against police officers is bad
how about this how about you stop making
the argument that the police are
systemically racist without any evidence
or any possible solutions or any
policies that have to be changed
but they won't do that because the cops
are in fact always bad in fact they're
so bad that they should
basically sit there while they are
abused or while people charge them with
knives or while people jump on the hoods
of their cars and attempt to assault
them
really the cops should basically just
absorb it because that's what they're
there to do
aren't they okay well we've run out of
time on today's podcast but later on
today we'll be here for two additional
hours we'll discuss
president trump's rally that he held in
nevada now two things can be true at
once
that uh it is a bad idea to hold a giant
indoor rally in the middle of a cove
pandemic
and two that the nevada governor really
has no leg to stand on because
all the casinos are open in nevada so
those two things can both be true we'll
get to that a little bit later on today
plus we'll get to universities going
full woke apparently the columbia
marching band
i'm not kidding you the colombia
marching band just they decided to
dissolve
because of their institutional racism
the marching band probably because of
those french horns
the french we'll get to that a little
bit later on otherwise we'll see you
here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2020. you know the matte wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about i hope
you'll
give it a listen